if you had the option of skipping
traffic while coming from point a to b
would you take it
what if it was in the sky
electric flying taxis are a lot closer
to reality than what we think
but the big question is how will people
perceive these flying objects and that
is why volocopter is showcasing its
aircraft here in singapore
the volo city
is a fully electric aircraft which is
designed for the inner city mission
it caters for the highest safety
for low noise
and for a fully electric flight one big
obstacle is that
not a single electric flying taxi has
regulatory approvals in place
companies like volocopter do believe
that they will get it pretty soon enough
just in time for the 2024 paris olympics
but regulators will take their time to
ensure these flying vehicles are
actually safe enough
we have 18 fully electric motors
and if we lose one or two motors or if
they are not working
we can still safely perform our mission
airlines have an ambitious target of
turning carbon neutral by 2050
while electric flying taxis are not
expected to replace airbus a320s or
boeing 737s in the near term this is
definitely a first step in that
direction
we are sitting inside the velocity
and as you can see it's very comfortable
you have a lot of leg space which you
normally don't have at a conventional
helicopter
but you also can see it's a two-seater
and this is the autonomous version
in the starting configuration we will
have a pilot sitting here and a
passenger
and in the autonomy version you don't
need that anymore the big question is
how much are these things going to cost
volocopter says it will be 40 cheaper
than helicopters to begin with and
eventually it will be at par
with premium taxes that means
anybody who can afford a taxi can afford
a flying taxi
this is how we move i am anurag kotoki
for more stories like this please follow
us on your favorite platforms